TUCKER IS COMING UP NEXT AND WE
WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
I'M ♪ ♪   ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE ARE JUST HOURS FROM THE 2018
MIDTERM ELECTIONS AS YOU WELL
KNOW, AND THE NOISE LEVELS ARE
BECOMING ALMOST UNBEARABLE.
EVERYONE IS POSTURING AND TRYING
TO BULLY YOU INTO THIS OR THAT
CANDIDATE AND IT'S ALL VERY
LOUD.
BUT PAUSE FOR A SECOND AND
CONSIDER WHAT YOU ARE NOT
HEARING.
WHAT IS MISSING FROM THIS
CACOPHONY?
FOR STARTERS, THERE IS HARDLY
WORD ABOUT RUSSIA.
REMEMBER THAT DASTARDLY
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THE PLOT THAT
HACKED OUR DEMOCRACY?
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THAT?
AND WHY WE ARE AT IT, WHAT ABOUT
BRETT KAVANAUGH?
WHAT ABOUT HIS HIGH SCHOOL
YEARBOOK AND HIS PURPORTED
TEENAGE DRINKING PROBLEM AND
THOSE GANG RAPES THAT HE
SUPPOSEDLY COMMITTED?
WHAT ABOUT THOSE?
THOSE WERE THE BIGGEST STORIES
IN THE WORLD NOT SO LONG AGO,
24/7 ON THE OTHER CABLE CHANNELS
AND THOSE STORIES WILL DEFINE
THIS ELECTION AND IT DEFINED THE
ENTIRE HISTORICAL ERA.
EVERYONE ON TELEVISION TOLD US
THAT.
NOW THESE ARE JUST FADING
MEMORIES.
IT TURNS OUT THEY WERE
SIDESHOWS.
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS WERE NEVER
GOING TO BE FOUGHT OVER
VLADIMIR PUTIN OR BRETT
KAVANAUGH OR JUST ABOUT ANYTHING
ELSE WE SPENT MOST OF OUR TIME
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS ELECTION LIKE ALL ELECTIONS
WAS GOING TO TURN ON ISSUES THAT
ACTUALLY AFFECT THE LIFE OF THE
COUNTRY.
THIS YEAR THERE ARE THREE BIG
ISSUES.
IMMIGRATION, THE ECONOMY AND
NATIONALISM.
THE FIRST IS THE MOST OBVIOUS.
IMMIGRATION DETERMINES WHO LIVES
NEXT DOOR TO YOU.
IT DETERMINES WHO WORKS IN YOUR
OFFICE AND WHO CHOOSES YOUR
LEADERS.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
FUNDAMENTAL IN ANY COUNTRY THAN
THE A QUESTION OF CITIZENSHIP.
WHATEVER DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T
KNOW, HE DEFINITELY KNOWS THIS.
HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION FOR THREE YEARS NOW.
AND ALL THAT TIME THE OFFICIAL
WASHINGTON HAS BEEN TRYING TO
MAKE HIM STOP.
>> THE WAY THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS
BEEN CONDUCTING THIS CAMPAIGN,
ATTACKING BROWN PEOPLE AND
MAKING UP STORIES ABOUT POSSIBLY
GEORGE SOROS FUNDING CARAVANS
THAT ARE STILL 800 MILES AWAY TO
TRY TO SCARE WHITE VOTERS.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS,
SHUT UP, RACIST.
BUT TRUMP WILL NOT SHUT UP SO
THEY HAVE CHANGED TACTICS.
THE NEWLINE IS, IMMIGRATION
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER.
THE THREAT IS HYPED AND ONLY
DUMB PEOPLE AND BIGOTS CARE
ABOUT BORDERS.
BY THE WAY, PARTIES OF BOTH
SIDES SEEM TO BELIEVE THIS.
PAUL RYAN'S OFFICE, LET IT BE
KNOWN TO POLITICO THIS MORNING
THAT THEY ASKED HIM TO STOP
YAMMERING ABOUT THE CARAVAN FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA AND TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING IMPORTANT LIKE
PAUL RYAN'S TAX BILL.
THAT'S PREEMPTIVE BLAME SHIFTING
OBVIOUSLY.
IF THE REPUBLICANS LOSE
TOMORROW, PAUL RYAN CAN POINT
THE FINGER AT TRUMP RATHER THAN
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR NOT
FUNDING THE WALL THAT VOTERS
SAID THEY WANTED.
BUT IT'S ALSO A LUDICROUS
POSITION TO TAKE BECAUSE IT'S
UNTRUE.
IMMIGRATION DOES MATTER.
IF, FOR EXAMPLE, ARIZONA AND
TEXAS GO TO THE DEMOCRATS
TOMORROW, IMMIGRATION WILL BE
THE REASON.
THOSE ARE REPUBLICAN STATES
UNTIL THE POPULATION CHANGED.
SO NO MATTER HOW MUCH YOU LIE
ABOUT IT, IMMIGRATION IS
INHERENTLY IMPORTANT AND VOTERS
UNDERSTAND THAT.
IF YOU WANT PEOPLE TO STOP
WORRYING ABOUT THE BORDER, THEN
YOU SHOULD SECURE THE BORDER AND
IT WON'T BE AN ISSUE.
PEOPLE ARE ALSO WORRIED ABOUT
OTHER THINGS THAT WASHINGTON
DOESN'T NOTICE OR THINKS IS
IMPORTANT.
HERE IN WASHINGTON, THE ECONOMY
IS SYNONYMOUS WITH THE STOCK
MARKET.
MARKETS HAVE BOOMED FOR TEN
YEARS AND THEIR ENTIRE CABLE
CHANNELS ARE DEVOTED TO
CHRONICLING THAT BOOM.
HERE IN WASHINGTON THE
ASSUMPTION IS THE ECONOMY MUST
ALSO BE BOOMING BUT THE TRUTH IS
AFTER A DECADE OF STOCKS GOING
HIGHER, THE EFFECT, THE POSITIVE
ONES ARE STILL NOT VERY OBVIOUS
OUTSIDE OF SELECT ZIP CODES ON
THE COAST.
IN MIDDLE AMERICA PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THEY WILL MOST
CERTAINLY MAKE LESS THAN THEIR
PARENTS MADE WHICH WILL BE A
REVERSAL OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THEY KNOW THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
BUY CARS OR BUY HOUSES, THEY ARE
NOT GETTING MARRIED OR HAVING
KIDS.
OUR CURRENT ECONOMIC SYSTEM
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT THAN
EVER THAN FAMILIES TO FORM.
WASHINGTON SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY
PANICKED ABOUT THIS.
IT IS THE MOST BASIC SIGN OF
FAILURE, THEY ARE FAILURE, BUT
NOBODY IN EITHER PARTY SEEMS TO
CARE.
THEIR ANSWER IS TO IMPORT NEW
FAMILIES FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
SO MAYBE IT'S NOT SO SURPRISING
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE SAY THEY LIKE
SOCIALISM?
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS NOT
WORKING FOR THEM, AND UNLESS WE
FIX THAT WE MAY GET ACTUAL
SOCIALISM WHICH WILL BE A
DISASTER.
AND THAT LEADS TO THE THIRD
ISSUE OF THIS ELECTION WHICH IS
NATIONALISM.
DESPITE WHAT YOU ARE HEARING DAY
IN AND DAY OUT, NATIONALISM IS
NOT A RACIAL CATEGORY.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE
OR ETHNICITY.
NATIONALISM IS THE BELIEF THAT
LEADERS OUGHT TO PUT THE
INTEREST OF THEIR OWN COUNTRIES
ABOVE THOSE OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT'S VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF DECLARED
HIMSELF THE NATIONALIST OF THE
OTHER NIGHT.
WATCH.
>> President Trump: THEY HAVE
A WORD, IT SORT OF BECAME
OLD-FASHIONED.
IT'S CALLED A NATIONALIST.
AND I SAID REALLY, WE ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO USE THAT WORD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I AM?
I'M A NATIONALIST.
>> Tucker: TRUMP IS A
NATIONALIST SO IN NORMAL TIMES
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ANNOUNCING THAT
HIS MAIN GOAL IS PROTECTING THE
UNITED STATES WOULD NOT QUALIFY
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1I
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1U
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1E
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1S
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1A
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1O
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1,
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1E
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1Y
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1L
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1A
AS NEWS BECAUSE ON TILL ABOUT 1F
EVERY NATION STATE THROUGHOUT
HISTORY HAS BEEN A NATIONALIST
THREAT DEFINITION.
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT WAS A
NATIONALIST AND SO WAS MAHATMA
GANDHI AND NELSON MANDELA.
YET SUDDENLY IT'S AN
ABOMINATION.
>> NATIONALIST.
USE THAT WORD.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT
WORD TONIGHT.
IT'S A FAVOR OF THE OUTRIGHT AND
IT'S LOADED WITH UNDERTONES.
AND SOME USE IT AS A SLUR
AGAINST THOSE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OFTEN WITH
ANTI-SEMITIC OVERTONES, WHICH
HAPPENS TO MAKE THE PRESIDENT
COME RIGHT OUT AND EMBRACE
NATIONALISM OPENLY.
AND CLAIM THAT MANTLE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE?
>> WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY AS
A PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AS YOU ARE A NATIONALIST.
IT'S NOT EVEN A DOG WHISTLE,
IT'S A BULLHORN.
>> Tucker: DUMB PEOPLE
REPEATING THEIR SAME TALKING
POINTS.
SO NATIONALISM IS NO PROFANITY.
TWITTER AND FACEBOOK WILL SURELY
BE BANNING THAT TERM IF THEY
HAVEN'T ALREADY.
BUT WHY?
WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING ON HERE?
WHY ARE THEY SO INTENT ON
STAMPING OUT NOT JUST A CONCEPT
BUT THE VERY WORD?
IT'S SIMPLE.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING HIS PEOPLE
PROTECTING THEIR OWN
PREROGATIVES.
GLOBALIZATION WHICH IS THE
OPPOSITE OF NATIONALISM HAS
CAUSED AN ENORMOUS TRANSFER OF
WEALTH FROM THE AMERICAN MIDDLE
CLASS TO WHAT WE USED TO CALL
THE THIRD WORLD TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTO
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTI
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTS
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTC
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTO
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTE
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTD
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTB
AMERICANS         AMERICAN FACTT
THEY WENT TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
SOME NATIONS GOT RICH FROM THIS
AND OTHERS GOT POORER.
RATHER THAN ADMIT WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED THOUGH, THE PEOPLE WHO
GOT RICH OR ARE TRYING TO MAKE
THE PEOPLE WHO GOT POOR OR SHUT
UP AND STOP COMPLAINING ABOUT I
IT.
A BORDERLESS WORLD HAS BEEN
HUGELY PROFITABLE FOR THEM AND
THAT'S WHY THEY SUPPORT IT.
NATIONALISM IS THAT KRYPTONITE
SO THEY MUST STOP IT.
THEY SCREAM RACISM AND HOPE THAT
NATIONALISM WILL GO AWAY.
WILL IT GO AWAY?
PROBABLY NOT.
BECAUSE THE CORE IDEA IS
APPEALING TO PEOPLE, ALL PEOPLE
IN ALL COUNTRIES OVERALL TIME.
PEOPLE WANT LEADERS WHO ARE
ABOVE ALL ON THEIR SIDE.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE WANTED THAT AND
THEY ALWAYS WILL WANT THAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE ELECTIONS
TOMORROW.